in this video I want to talk about
monosaccharides which are just simple
sugars I want to talk about the
difference in how to draw the D form
versus the L form and the alpha anomer
versus the beta anomer and I'm going to
do this for actually I'm actually just
going to show you the Haworth
projections for all these different
sugars but I'm only going to do the
example for one particular sugar and
then I'll post a link for you guys that
kind of gives you a description of all
these different monosaccharides okay but
first thing I want to do I'm going to
draw the first example I wanted to do is
glucose and specifically I want to do
beta-d-glucose so glucose is a six
membered ring with the oh in the top
right and because of D I have a ch2oh
pointing up now the way I remember how
to draw glucose is I think of when I
think of glucose I think of Milk Duds
because Milk Duds are sweet and they're
full of sugar and glucose is a sugar and
that's fun and easy okay
so in order to kind of understand why
you I even wrote up debt here is that we
have the number of these carbons keep an
eye on so there's six five let's carbon
number four three two and one so it's
six those of the six carbons there
okay now this in order is carbons 2 3 4
and this dud here D u D stands for down
up down so the O H on the second carbon
goes down the which and the third carbon
goes up and the Oh H and the fourth
carbon goes down ok so that's how I
remember that now I want to split the
page in half and kind of show you how
that's different from alpha D glucose in
just a second what about the Oh weights
that goes on the first carbon because
it's beta the Oh H is going to go up and
be on the same side as the ch2oh okay so
the way I kind of keep that in mind
because I think of beta equals batter up
that's just help what helps train you
remember that specifically for the D
form right
but the technical definition of veda is
that the OAH the on the NM eric carbon
which is this carbon right that Oh H is
going to be sis on the same side to the
ch2oh right they're both on the same
side they're both up okay so how does
this differ from alpha D glucose well
alpha D glucose differs only at the
anomeric carbon right so most of it is
going to be actually let me draw that a
little bit bigger alpha deep blue cose
looks like this so it's still a d sugar
so the ch2oh is going to be up like that
and this is still going to be down up
down right four carbons two three and
four the only difference is that instead
of the always group going up the Oh H
group is going to come down so that it's
alpha so I know that alpha has to be
trans right the o H group has to be
transferred to ch2oh and there they are
this one's going up and this one's
coming down so the out this O age group
is trans to the ch2oh okay now how do
you draw the L forms of these well the
way I remember it is that if I just draw
the D form the L form is the same thing
except everything that was up is now
going to be down and everything that was
down is now going to be up so if I draw
a beta L glucose right that's going to
be the enantiomer of this so still the
six membered rings like this with the O
up oops with the O right here right now
instead of a ch2 going up it's going to
come down below the plane this was down
up down those are all going to be
reversed so it's going to be up down up
right and this Oh H was up so now it's
going to go down notice that this is
still beta right so we expect to see the
Oh H group on the anomeric carbon we
want that in turmeric carbon Oh H to
still be on the same side as the ch2oh
and it is okay so I'm going to the
circle
America carbons in purple okay so now
I'm going to do alpha L glucose and
that's going to look like alpha D
glucose except everything's flipped
upside down ch2oh comes down there's
going to be up down up for these O H's
and here the o H was down so now it's
going to go up and it's still trans to
the ch2oh because it's alpha okay so now
the kind of way to remember I'm going to
do a few more sugars right doing glucose
galactose fructose ribose and
deoxyribose because those are the most
important ones to biochemistry I'm not
going to manipulate them all in the same
way instead I'm gonna like I said I'm
gonna link you to a sort of PDF of all
these different sugars draw in the
correct way
so I'm henceforth for the rest of these
sugars I'm only going to draw the beta D
form and then I would expect that you
would manipulate it according to the to
the sort of the way you should remember
it so so beta D galactose is also a six
carbon sugar and it's in this six
membered ring as well so beta D
galactose it's D so the ch2 is going to
H is going to go up but now it's not
going to be a milk dud for this one it's
duu okay so again carbons two three and
four so it's going to go down up up
those were the OHS go now it's beta so
it's going to have going to go up and be
on the same side as a ch2oh okay so this
is beta D galactose alright now the next
one I want to do and support anymore
like I mentioned I'm only going to draw
the beta D forms okay because that's
sort of the way I remember it I just
remember the beta D forms or the out the
D form really and then I just remember
how to manipulate it if I want something
else right so here the next one is going
to be fructose okay so I'm going to draw
a baited
you fructose now for toast it's a little
bit weird it's a six carbon molecule
it's six carbon sugar actually then we
go through and and note really quickly
here that this glucose is a six carbon
sugar galactose is a six carbon sugar as
well fructose is also a six carbon sugar
but fructose is a little bit different
in that it's a six carbon sugar but it's
in a five membered ring okay so this
five membered ring looks like this for
fructose where the O is up top here okay
so it's still a D sugar so the ch2oh
here the six carbon is going to be
pointing up okay so now let's number
these carbons like we did with glucose
because now we have a five membered ring
so that might be a little bit different
so 6 5 4 3 2 or missing the last one so
I'll actually show you what happens in
just a second but for fructose I think
of the acronym
I think of fructose is just you D right
foot so that's just 4 carbons 3 & 4
right so this one's going to go so
carbon number 3 is going to be pointing
up carbon number 4 is me pointing down
okay now it's beta-d-glucose which means
that the OHS has to be on the same side
as the ch2oh so the OAH going to go up
this way so that's going to be beta but
now where is that that first carbon well
it's going to be right down here as
ch2oh okay so that's where carbon number
1 is okay in case that was kind of
confusing so for just a little bit weird
there okay but the same idea applies is
that this here's the anomeric carbon and
that for in order to draw this you would
just manipulate it in very much the same
way that we did up here with glucose
okay so that's glucose galactose
fructose two more that we want to do arm
first one let's do ribose so let's do
the beta D form of ribose
okay so ribose is also in a five
membered ring right and ribose is
actually a five carbon sugar okay so
it's actually a five carbon sugar so it
doesn't have a ch2oh hanging off this
first carbon here so d sugar ch2oh goes
up right ribose
I think RDD ribose dd-down down right
and that's four carbons number carbon
number is three and four okay so the
carbons are numbered six five four three
oops not six there's I just said it was
a five carbon sugar am i doing this is
carbon number five four three two one
so excuse me here this is actually
carbon number two and this is carbon
number three okay forgive me for that
error at least I caught it okay so here
carbon number two we're gonna have an O
H going down and this carbon number
three and o H going down okay now it's
beta so the O H gonna be on the same
side is ch2oh so what's up and that's it
that's ribose okay ribose is important
when we're talking about nucleic acids
right RNA ribonucleic acids this is the
sugar the five of the pentose sugar that
they're actually concerned with right
pentose five carbons six carbons is a
hexose okay so last one I want to
mention is deoxyribose which looks like
this it looks pretty much exactly like
um ribose so I want to draw the beta D
deoxyribose okay which is also a five
carbon sugar okay it looks nearly
identical to ribose the only difference
is that the two prime or the to the the
second carbon carbon number two instead
of its its deoxy it doesn't have an
oxygen here at
carbon number two is just the hydrogen
hydrogen and other hydrogen here okay so
here there's no there's no Oh age group
okay so it looks just like ribose looks
just like ribose like ribose except
carbon two has no Oh H group right and
that's where the deoxy comes from you
lose that hydrogen it's just it's just a
hydrogen at the the second carbon there
okay so we go back to these carbons 1 2
3 4 5 ok so this is beta D deoxyribose
so let's not forget this Oh H going up
here so then that that's essentially it
um what I'll have now is if you want to
draw any of the other forms you would
simply manipulate them knowing that that
you know all these different things here
that if you want to turn it from a d2l
sugar you just take everything that was
up and put it down everything that was
down and put it up and then keep in mind
that the beta has to be assist to the
ch2oh and the Alpha has to be translated
ch2oh like I said I'll post a PDF along
with this video so that you can see how
the remainder of these drawings look
okay I hope that was helpful and good
luck studying this stuff